questa era telo che vi piace la mia
gamba pelosa sta ascoltando a terra
swift scusarlo ho visto il video che era
partito bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono taylor swift e da
gestione nuovo episodio di the forest
dove già si è partiti bis trani quindi
il vi lascio al video bella linea e io
corro eco robbie a porca [ __ ] corre
veloce però devo arrivare assolutamente
al mio rifugio prima di morire ott io ti
ringrazio sia arrivato al rifugio
ci ho messo una vita e mezza come si
scende piano piano la [ __ ] solo di
morire per un attimo mi sono cagate in
mano vai dormi gesù ti ringrazio che
giorno è mercoledì ma sii saprei ma si
sa a questo hai dormito con l'accendino
così ma di me lo so che bello finito di
questo di sta roba mi ricordo anche più
che cazzo serve prove se promette alla
carne giusto è una specie di macelleria
improvvisata da pj macelleria da fa vj
solo alla miglior carne di aborigeno
posso anche appendere la carne da morigi
no non ci credo ma come la scossa ma non
è vero ma chi li assume la sala mangia
la gamba di aborigeno naga schifo dato
mi serviva la nostra viva la testa ho
finito gli darò fuoco quando arriverà
qualcuno a rompermi le balle perchè se
dai fuoco a sta roba non si avvicinano
credo e mi pare di aver capito così ma
dai è cresciuto la piantina che figata
bene allora mentre la gamba rimane lì ad
essiccare darei un occhiata ancora in
giro perché ho visto delle robe
abbastanza utili ringraziando iddio
ragazzi giusto modo di salire sopra che
che ho inventato che è una figata
assurdo cioè praticamente basso a
scalare le rocce normali ci metto un po
per o meno una volta che conosci le
rocce una cagata tipo salti quale ha
scalato la montagna manco bear grylls
fantastico stavo dicendo non ho trovato
nessun superstite ma neanche uno eppure
c'è scritto che ci dovrebbero essere ho
capito se li sono portati nelle caverne
ragazzi devo tornare nelle caverne tanto
tutto quello che mi serve qualche figli
de na [ __ ] ladra guarda che figli
possa campano davanti o che nervi avevo
trovato nel primo episodio che non l'ho
trovata più una specie di caverna che
veramente si scendeva da sopra ci ha per
niente era un fosso e c'era andato
qualcuno di umano perché per niente
perché c'era una corda per scendere 15
erano andati gli esseri umani potrebbero
esserci dei superstiti da dentro anche
qua c'è la caverna normale perfetto
fatevi dare un'occhiata in giro
prevedere se trova la botola tipo la
specie di botta da tipo lost siamo in
realtà ragazzi noi stiamo giocando
all'osso e poi trovata ragazzino trovata
ho trovata ma è pieno di aborigeni porca
eva ce la posso fare
giù scendi scendi scendi scendi se news
l'ater vai per la madonna che muscolari
ma che cazzo sei rambo ragazzi stiamo
sto scendendo quando ci sono ancora
acceso spero e prego di trovare qualcuno
madonna che prova quanto quanto profonda
ma gesù ma dio mio ma poi guarda fermi
fermi fermi questo rumore bruttissimo
che cosa cazzo sei
no no no no no no no no no no no no
regano mi piace eppure devo scendere di
qua per andare avanti e lega come faccio
e impossibile una donna che brutta solo
è certo senti fatti i cazzi tuoi
sono i bambini aborigeni che che sono
deformi potrebbero esserci superstiti il
problema è che non so se sopravvivo io
allora facciamo così appena scendo
attacco a correre c'è una luce li provo
ad accorrere verso la luce subito ai
staccati staccati una [ __ ]
garri bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye
bye bye bye bye bye bye bye bye con
ricordi c'è una luce
dio mio dio mio
in seguito a cristo che infarto sono
vivo sono vivo non so che casse questa
roba fluttua mingardi un live iosa non
ho capito perché frutto quella roba lì
però vabbè messo ci sono superstiti qui
perché io devo mettermi a cercare
superstiti in una caverna dove si entra
e c'è un mostro appena scendi come
potrebbe mai essere vivo qualcuno tranne
team i temi non possono averlo ucciso un
bambino teme temi sei qua dentro la
lurida bimbo della minchia
o cristo no scherzavo e vabbè rega ori
velocissimo come dovrei fare la destra
non c'è niente davanti non c'è niente
l'unico punto è questo allora facciamo
così luce spenta ci sto passando
vicinissimo ci sono praticamente ciglio
in faccia visto mi ci credo mai soldi
cazzo ci fate coi soldi ci giocate a
poker
il tuo rumore di una cascata raga io
sono non so dove ciglio se cio a destra
sinistra non lo so raga non vedo dove
sto andando deve usarlo un attimino
perché sono veramente non vedo niente
non avere dentro una roccia giusto
pipistrelli o ragazzi fermi e fermi che
se volate spaventate tutti sì sì ho
superato quel punto lì non so neanch'io
come reagan non lo so piano è che che
minchia non so dove stiamo finendo non
ne ho la più pallida idea piano calata
la [ __ ] testa di merda ad un
pipistrello ha fatto cagare in mano sto
deficit mi piacerà una tensione
incredibile colo colo fi diverse a
pipistrello ma come ti permetti sembra
non esserci nessuno c'è un tavolo ci
sono denti appesi al soffitto dove
minchia sia infinite allora è questo è
l'unico punto dell'adhd di tutto il
gioco che non ho ancora visto questo
trovato
ho trovato qualcosa però non ho capito
cosa però è il credo che serva per
andare avanti nel gioco perché ha fatto
un rumore stranissimo quando l'ho
trovato era un pezzo di giocatore del
bambino broken toy eccolo quindi è
passato di qua team i fatti sentire
appagati me che me ne frego di qua io ho
ragazzi sono due strade allora ce n'era
una vicino al tavolo e un'altra di qua
quindi segue prima questa se qualcosa si
mette male me ne vado nell'altra ti
trovo ti trovo ti trovo ti trovo lo
troverò lega fosse l'ultima cosa che
faccio trovo a grazie grazie che avete
fatto questa rampa per cos'è per farci
passare i motorini grazie no perché
pensavo che howard che gentile anche la
discesa grazie mille adesso sì che non
ho fatto lo scalino e si che sono pieno
di vita visto non mi ha visto mi ha
visto porca [ __ ] sam ha visto l'ha
visto subito devi morire e vabbè non
l'ho preso di fatti i cazzi tuoi addio
non fermi fermi a via via via via via
via via via via via via via via subito a
una bella roba famo una bellissima roba
prendi questa se si avvicina qualcuno
gli spari in bocca proprio nel morire
subito te lo devi infilare nel culo
tutto ciao frate bravo sei brava a
ballare molto bella è incazzato quanto
mi dispiace perchè non vieni anche tu a
giocare dove cazzo dove sei
il cag in mano è che cela pistolina dove
sei salve ho mancato sono un deficiente
dai dai dai dai dai che l'opinione che
lo piglia
ho finito i colpi porca merda che brutto
momento per finire colpi che brutto
momento
no non è vero non ci credo mai
santo ed io cosa ho appena visto bene
bene bene bene bene bene bene bene
vabbè mica mi sono massacrato bravo
bravo zio vai senti solo perché ti ha
ucciso il compagno quanta quante
lamentele quantestorie dovrei farti
cazzi tuoi
ok non so neanche dove stiamo andando
non ne ho la più pallida idea per ora
qualche parte deve condurre il suo posto
cioè sono arrivato a una cascata
qualcuno mi appello c'è l'uscita solo
che non ci arriverò mai fantastico e
vabbè non fa niente possiamo di carico
c'è qualcosa siamo arrivati non si
accende
ti prego oddio mi chiami son cagati in
mano pensò fosse un mostro ma fan cuore
avete sentito ragazzo è qualcuno che ha
fatto un verso bruttissimo e non sono
stato io credo dove sei chi sei fatti
vedere vade retro c'è un passaggio
camino attack è bello trovato da dove mi
sto dove sto andando scavalca dai media
e l'uscita vedo bene vedo bene o vedo
male ma che cazzo ma non è un bug
ho trovato un bug del gioco ma fermi
cos'è sta roba
ma sei serio ma no timmy 6 perché sotto
le texture del gioco io sto passando
dentro delle parti in cui non dovrei
passare per ogni anno vado avanti
e giusto che bello che posso vedere la
mappa da sotto sempre così ragazzi nei
giochi io devo trovare i bugs non sono
contento ma che bello la distesa davanti
a gesù parla molto su grossi stack
averne guarda guarda quante caverne
enormi ci sono dio mio no loro fermo
scherzavo l'odioso rimasto incastrato
no rimasto incastrato nel terreno però
non posso morire e noi tanto noi non c'è
niente sotto vedo l'alba vengo l'alba
dei tempi
gesù aiutami aiutami dimmi che bello tra
ma niente continueremo a cadere per il
resto della nostra vita
ho provato a trovarti timi
ci ho provato sono andato incontro ad un
destino di un intestino sono andati
incontro a un destino orribile solo per
salvarti team di a tua madre che la amo
ok brutte ciabatte del cazzo servita a
qualcosa fate qualcosa salvatemi la vita
aiuta o tanto freddo tanto freddo check
check check cam ignota ma perché ma
perché timido
dove cazzo sono o mio dio ma seriamente
e quindi ragazzi concludo che questo
episodio spero che video vi sia piaciuto
e cosa gli sia piaciuto al documento è
un mi piace
ok la smetto anche a pagina di facebook
come le video trattare iscrizione si
tiene ci vediamo fosse vivo